you growing outrage over liberal soft on
crime policies after a scary attack on a
republican candidate new york
and there's only
there's only one option
the man who tried to stab gubernatorial
candidate congressman lee zeldin is back
on the streets just hours after his
arrest the assault happening while zelda
was giving a speech about weak bail
reform laws in new york
the da's office charging the suspect
with a felony for attempted assault but
no bail
and get this zelda predicted his
attacker would get off easy tweeting the
attack will likely be ins the attacker
will likely be instantly released under
new york's laws congressman zeldin going
after the liberal laws in an interview
you can catch tonight on hannity right
here on fox you have a person who is
saying you're done he repeated that he's
lunging at me with this weapon with the
two daggers coming out of it similar to
brass knuckles
he is charged with a a violent felony
and he is instantly released back on the
street because of new york's cashless
bail laws i i saw it coming i wish it
wasn't this way and we keep hearing too
many of these stories
judge
why should this man be back on the
street
why is he back home because the law
allows for him to be back on the street
and the amazing part of this is good old
governor hochul the accidental governor
who got there because the guy before was
corrupt the democrat governor that is
um she says that you know her heart goes
out to zelda or whatever she said again
i i'm really tired of complaining about
her she talks to talk she doesn't walk
the walk if she had any concern about
crime victims like lee zeldin could have
been it was an attempted assault in the
second degree
um you got brass knuckles with two edges
uh on the brass knuckles it could have
killed him it didn't kill him they
grabbed him ahead of time but he should
have been um he should have been
incarcerated and there should have been
a 7 30 as we call it in new york to see
if he's a danger to himself or others
that wasn't happening and in the end
this guy is back out on the streets he
probably got his brass knuckles back too
uh and he's free to do it again and
hogel gets out there and says you know
we feel bad about this you're full of it
hocal you're a
hypocrite because
you will not allow for the legislature
to get a bill and put it on your desk to
change cashless bail so we can make an
assessment of bail which is in the
constitution we didn't make this stuff
up uh so that we can incarcerate those
people who deserve to be incarcerated
until we know who they are
greg speaking of governor hulkel she her
team tweet or put on their website and
posted uh lee zeldin's his rallies the
schedule and they kind of poke fun and
say hey make sure you go check this out
coming on the heels of what happened
with kavanaugh and the supreme court the
things that schumer said and only took
back once there was an assassination
attempt i mean is this just the next
thing that's happening as far as how bad
we are in our rhetoric with each other
you are so naive first of all she's a
democrat so her rhetoric doesn't matter
fair enough and he's a republican so it
doesn't matter that he got attacked so
the the you know i would like you know i
kept saying that i hope that these
screwed up policies would finally won't
hit home but will hit home if it hits
people in power if the crime comes to
your house i forgot to be specific it
actually has to be a democrat because no
one in the media cares about republicans
this is a perfect encapsulation of
liberal criminal reform this is like i
mean you couldn't ask for a better
that's the speech he was making and it
happened it's pretty amazing if hokal
had half a brain which is
twice what she's currently housing uh
she would fire alvin brad to to steer
the story back to this you know i'm
solving catch and release criminality
but she's dumber than three cuomo's
combined and she couldn't spell cat if
you spotted her the c the a and the t
so we're gonna see more of this and we
just saw something california see that
guy got
let out uh five years into his 50-year
murder sentence and the first thing he
did he went to let the cops on a car
chase high on drugs with a gun so this
is everywhere and
how many more people have to die sounds
cliche to say that but it's because
people are dying
people are dying people are being
released without bell that have
committed violent crimes now we watch
that video kennedy the guy looks drunk
yes he doesn't look like he can
physically
kill a sober lee zeldin but that's kind
of beside the point isn't it like the
the optics are not the crime the crime
is he brought a weapon on stage and said
you're done and physically assaulted
lee's elbow so if he were half as drunk
and had better name would he still have
been released it's because he didn't
have good aim and that's not reason
enough this is still a violent person
you know intent should mean something
and when you're lunging at someone with
a double blade saying you're done you're
done you're done clearly the intent is
not a high five this is not dusty baker
you know that this is someone who
it you know the least of all needs help
and even the the head of amvets because
this was a a veterans charity event he
said like i'm going to help this guy
because the government hasn't helped him
so you know it's like to the judge's
point he should have at least been sent
to a hospital for an evaluation so he
could have gotten something well and
jessica i kind of want to throw this to
you we here at nauseum for good reason
because you know children being shot in
schools
it's appalling and tragic and we have to
take action even as a pro-gun guy i say
that
what that action is is where we dispute
a lot of times right but the guy i
interviewed joe tinelli i believe head
of amvets who tackled him and he said
that he had a conversation with him
while wrestling him to the ground and
what he learned he was probably a vet
and he's probably having a mental health
crisis yeah and this is the next thing
that's happened that mental health is a
part of that
when do we start saying hey it doesn't
have to end in tragedy to still be
something that we need to take action on
and is letting someone out of the job is
there no mechanism to say hey you're
having a mental crisis let's at least
quarantine you and figure this out
well i think i mean people do talk a big
talk as well beat myself about talk
twice about how important mental health
is and there has been in some cities
you know funding moved away from the
police to go to mental health resources
and social workers etc because a lot of
this is not actually necessarily about
you know the criminality but the root
causes of why they are pulling this it
was a cat key chain that he was carrying
that he probably just pulled out of his
pocket no it's definitely didn't show up
i'm saying it is a deadly weapon
website but
you have to be you have to be clear when
you say keychain you're diminishing the
fact that it has sharp edges and can
take out i don't need to i think this is
very serious i
i was not intending to belittle the
attack or the seriousness so that that
okay thank you why is it a key chain
letter well because it is
there should just be more attention on
all of these things there has to be a
re-evaluation of what qualifies as
non-violent because that actually is
violent right i mean it was it was in
slo-mo because he was drunk but it was
violent and you know obviously i'm not a
lawyer and i'm not a judge but it seems
like we should have a full-scale
re-evaluation of every piece of this
puzzle because i can guarantee that 90
of the horrible things that we see in
our city here in new york you see in los
angeles san francisco chicago et cetera
has a mental health root cause well
mental health and drug alcohol abuse but
that's part of it i mean people are
self-medicating and key chains don't
forget the key chains just
jessica you're absolutely right then
there should be a comment in prison all
right we gotta go it's a violent crime
it's attempted murder in my opinion
just because the gun wasn't involved uh
maybe now people will take mental health
seriously if if guns aren't involved
then these things happen all right up
next just in time for the midterms the
liberal media all of a sudden saying
they got things wrong while trying to
suck up to trump supporters hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now